oh it's it's been decimated it's
horrible yeah yeah i mean i was thinking
i might be retiring you know in the next
year or two and now i'm i don't know i
don't know when i can do that
we have a tsp a 401 a 529 i don't want
to look at it
they're not doing too good right now
at all i've been losing a lot of money
it's not doing good
i just actually checked it while i was
inside and it's not doing good
uh
oops
there's nothing wrong i at this time
unfortunately
uh the stock market or the price is
inflation
everything is up there it's been painful
um i honestly had to take out
uh some funds out of my 401k to you know
support myself and my family with
inflation and everything else
i attribute it to primarily the economy
the handling of the economy the just
incredible excessive spending that the
democrats have done and you know it
feels like all of their policies are
really trying to destroy our economy and
destroy the middle class wow um so my
husband's tsp
and because we're not going to touch it
but this is a true story and that's why
it kind of hits home thank goodness we
have a large tsp
it went down two hundred thousand
dollars
it's looking okay
it's looking okay um i'm i'm young i'm
only 32 i'll be 32 next month so
i'm nowhere near retiring so yeah
they're all looking pretty bad right now
uh you know the dollar's not going as
far as it used to and i think everyone
feels it i would love to see my my 401k
go up oh boy don't even ask me now
you're hitting
[Music]
obviously last six months were not that
great
so for whatever you know
people earn in last two years in their
401k account or even in their investment
accounts
everything has been wiped up probably in
first six months first half of this year
so hopefully i mean recession is not too
far it looks like the way things are
going so
to move the things around
i don't know whether recession is the
solution for inflation or not but it
seems like you know economy is heading
in that way and i think some
things policy-wise are needed to get us
out of this problem next three months
assessments